treatments for colorectal cancer include
surgical procedures chemotherapy and
radiation therapy
early cancer or polyps may be removed
during a colonoscopy
during this procedure a flexible tube
will be inserted through your anus
in most cases if a polyp is found it
will be removed
if a small area of cancer is found it
will be removed
for larger areas of cancer you may need
to have a surgical procedure to remove
the affected part of your large
intestine
your surgeon may remove part of your
colon
or part or all of your rectum
nearby tissue such as lymph nodes may
also be removed to see if cancer has
spread there
in most cases the remaining ends of your
large intestine will be reattached
but sometimes the surgeon will not
attach the remaining ends right away
instead a procedure may be done to
attach the top end of your large
intestine to an
opening in the skin of your abdomen and
the bottom end will be closed with
staples or sutures
this new opening in the skin allows
solid waste to empty into an attached
bag
usually the opening is temporary if
temporary the ends of your large
intestine will be reconnected in a later
procedure
chemotherapy radiation therapy or both
may also be recommended
either before or after a surgical
procedure
chemotherapy uses drugs to attack and
kill cancer cells
radiation therapy is often used along
with chemotherapy
the high energy rays and radiation
therapy attack and destroy cancer cells
other treatments may also be recommended
for colorectal cancer
talk to your health care provider if you
have any questions
you